Let's go next to, where do we want to go?
Let's go to our caller from the nine to five
area code.
Who's calling today from nine to five.
Hi, Zoe.
Yeah, that's you.
Hi David.
I'm a huge fan of the show.
Um, I just wanted to ask you about again,
the impeachment process.
Um, right now, you know, with the release
of the transcripts, there seems to be clearly
enough evidence for impeachment.
But the vibe I'm getting from Republicans
is they see this as an absolute win.
They know that impeachment has like horrible
poor rating, I think.
I think it's around 30%.
I'm not sure.
And they think it'll help them in 2020.
Yeah.
It seems that both sides are assuming this
is a win for them and it seems that there's
going to be one clear winner and loser.
Um, um, I'm just going to ask like based on
this, do you see this as hurting the Democrats
in 2020 or helping them
it, so my commentary this week has been that
it depends on what actually happens and it's
basically three different things.
Number one, what information that was previously
unknown to the general public is revealed
through the impeachment inquiry process.
That's question number one.
Question number two, does Donald Trump successfully
turn himself into the victim martyr?
Whatever phrase you want to use, because that
would absolutely embolden Trump.
And then the other thing I think is important,
I don't know where you're getting the number
that only 30% of Americans are in favor of
impeachment.
Last I looked more than half of the country
was in favor of an impeachment inquiry.
I don't, I've not seen any evidence to suggest
that's changed.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I didn't know that.
Um, yeah, I mean that was, that was my question.
Thank you.
I'm curious about where did you get that 30%
of the country supports impeachment?
Um, I got it from, um, the Hill.
They just, uh, re put out a video today about
it, I think, and they mentioned it's around
30 to 35% I think.
Okay.
I'll check that out.
Yeah.
The polls I had seen revoked above 50%.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright, thank you.
Okay.
Thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.